aoc joins the met gala with a message
for all of her fellow wealthy marxists
and we discuss why the ritzy unearned
moral superiority of the met gala really
matters i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
inflation is setting in it is not
transitory any longer there are
estimates that this inflation is going
to last at least a year maybe two well
because things are inflating this would
be an excellent time to diversify into
something more solid than the american
dollar something like precious metals
what is your plan to protect your
savings you have homeowners insurance in
case of a fire what insurance do you
have in place of inflation continues to
ramp up my insurance plan is gold and
silver from birch gold group if you
haven't reached out to birch gold to
diversify your ira or 401k into a
precious metals ira go ahead and do it
today text ben to 47 47 47 get a free
information kit on protecting your
savings with gold they have an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews thousands of
happy customers talk to them have them
help you safeguard your retirement
savings folks over birch gold they know
what they're talking about they're gonna
be honest with you ask all your
questions get those questions answered
and then think seriously about taking a
portion of your wealth and putting it in
precious metals text ben 247 47 47 claim
you're free no obligation information
kit on holding gold and silver in a tax
shelter sheltered account again text ben
to 47 47 47 to take the first step in
protecting your savings today alrighty
so last night was the met gala and the
met gallup
is an excellent reminder that marxists
in the united states are cosplaying
revolution
okay they don't actually want a
revolution they don't really want much
of anything beyond simple
moral virtue signaling about how little
they like the systems under which they
have grown rich and famous
so what they do is they hobnob with one
another and they go to very fancy
parties and they wear very fancy clothes
and they talk about how dedicated they
are to the revolution see the thing is
when you're an actual revolutionary you
kill people who go to the mag right if
you are looking at the old school
communist revolution you go to the
tara's palace and you murder him in his
family if you're looking at the french
revolution the sounds kilo they go over
to the royals and they execute them what
they don't do is go to the party with
the royals and then wear slogans that
say down with the royals because then it
just looks frankly like you're kind of a
tool and in fact that is what the met
gala is it is a bunch of marxists
cosplaying marxism it is a bunch of
radicals cosplaying radicalism they're
not actually being radical
they're not actually going and
protesting the met gala in fact i think
what is what is so funny about this is
they are cosplaying two things at once
one is they're cosplaying the revolution
look at us we are so look we are
fighting the patriarchy by doing this
event on behalf
of the met gala to raise money for an
institution the metropolitan museum of
art that's been around for
over 100 years and is an institution
largely staffed by men and also we are
fighting capitalism by wearing these
expensive gowns
and these expensive tuxedos made by
companies that break in
money but they also put slogans on them
so that mean i mean we're real
revolutionaries so they're cosplaying
the revolution but they are also
cosplaying what marxists think
capitalists are it's amazing
i know lots of extraordinarily rich
people i know i know billionaires i know
multi-billionaires i know some of the
richest people on earth actually and let
me tell you they don't live like the
people at the met gal address the people
at the met gala
want you to think that this is what
capitalists live like but the only
people who live like this are the people
at temecula it is these celebrities who
spend their nights dressing like fools
wearing ten thousand dollar gowns that
look like
like a child made them in art class
it's an incredible thing and so i kind
of love them at gala because it exposes
them for the frauds they are
you know there's a very famous essay by
tom wolf it's maybe the best political
essay of all time it's called radical
chic uh it's a it's about it was
originally printed in york magazine it
was about a party at uh at leonard
bernstein's house and that party was
leonard bernstein and his then wife and
they get together in a penthouse with a
bunch of black panthers this is a cover
story for new york magazine
and the whole thing is hysterically
funny because it is a bunch of
upper-crust radical leftists who have
benefited from the systems of the united
states patronizing the black panthers
who show up and are telling them how
white pigs should be killed and all the
white people are just clapping for them
right that's that's the entirety of the
essay
well
the only difference between radical
sheik that tom wolf essay
and what happens at magella every year
is that they are actually not even
bringing in the black panthers they
don't actually bring in any radicals
they don't even bring anybody in to act
as sort of like the the exhibit at the
museum that they can stare at and say oh
those are the radicals we love them they
actually pretend to be them it's as
though at leonard bernstein's dinner
party leonard bernstein had dressed up
as a black panther and then declared
himself brave for doing so
that is what the met gala is every
single year
and it's and it's astonishing i mean it
really is and so we saw a lot of that
last night
we'll get to the we'll save the best for
last because we have to
but it began with folks like megan
rapino showing up and uh megan ropino
shows up wearing a a
red white and blue outfit and holding a
small purse that says in gay we trust
see because not god it's in gay we trust
you see like it's
the theme was american fashion because
nothing says respect for america like
replacing god with gay
and she's such a revolutionary megan
rapino she is standing up to the
patriarchy every single day she's
standing up to the patriarchy by making
money from the patriarchy
and um and appealing for the help of
male politicians and spending all day
long whining about her position as a
very wealthy white woman
who gets to play a sport that no one
watches other than once every four years
and be a social activist that has not
actually achieved
things so that's that's exciting stuff
but but at least she trusts in gay
that's pretty exciting and gay we trust
cause we had megan rapino and then we
had cara de la vine
and i'm maybe screwing up her name but
frankly i don't care because i really
don't know very much who she is
apparently she's some sort of model and
here she was modeling a bib slash
straight jacket
i don't know what this top is supposed
to be and it says peg the patriarchy oh
the courage oh the stunning courage and
bravery peg the patriarchy
because pegging of course is an obscure
sexual practice in which women uh
perform the uh the the more aggressive
sexual act on men peg the patriarchy
right
which
yeah
and she's pegging the patriarchy by
being a model
for the pleasure of men generally
speaking
and also she's pegging the patriarchy by
wearing scantily clad outfits that say
this and the patriarchy is quaking in
its boots let me tell you just i mean
wow the courage you know by the way
where the patriarchy is actually
dominant
you think a woman could wear this so in
afghanistan right now the patriarch is
pretty dominant if carol de la vine
walked out on the streets of afghanistan
she would be dead within approximately
22 seconds because she doesn't live in a
patriarchy that's the thing she lives in
a free republic
hey but pegged the patriarchy such
courage oh and doing it at the met gala
of all places she's not even doing it
like a truck stop in ohio she's doing it
at the met gala that's where the
patriarchy lives unbelievable courage
stunning bravery
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because it is indicative of the
culture gap that has emerged in the
united states and that actually has
basically divided the country everybody
thinks in the in the intelligentsia that
it's economics that divides america
economics does not divide americans
everybody seems to think that it's
policy that divides americans in some
cases it's policy but more than that it
is this cultural divide where you have
half the country that believes that
their politics are values and that their
values are better
that's what they actually believe they
believe that this is an act of courage
to wear a thing that says peg the
patriarchy to that gala
or to wear or to take a little purse
that says in gay we trust to the met
gala rebelling against the obviously
deeply homophobic board of the met gala
by the way i mean who are you rebelling
against i'm just i'm wondering to whom
are you speaking
like the the chairs of the 2021 met gala
are timothy chalamet
who most recently
was oscar nominated for playing a gay
person in a film which is still okay by
the way you're allowed to be straight
and play a gay guy which frankly i don't
understand that that seems like that
violates all the strictures that we have
been told exist when it comes to you're
not allowed to act like a person you're
not
billy eilish
obviously very homophobic amanda gorman
super homophobic and naomi osaka and tom
ford also is an honorary chair as is
adam moseri and anna wintour i mean can
you imagine a bigger level of anti-gay
bigotry than that and the courage of
megan rapino walking up wearing an in
gay we trust purse like unbelievable
they're all cosplaying revolution gang
it's cosplaying it is a mockery so i'm
glad they do it we need to get to the
best
we're getting there guys hang on first
let us talk about a simple fact
a lot of your equity is tied up in your
home it could be a fifty thousand bucks
hundred thousand bucks could be more
cyber crime experts are alerting
homeowners the more equity you have the
greater the chance foreign and domestic
criminals will come after you after all
as john zillinger once says the reason
that he robbed banks is because that's
where the money was the the basic
concept exists when it comes to home
equity as well home title theft is one
of the fastest growing crimes in fact
home title lock america's leader in home
title protection is alerting homeowners
that could already be a victim and not
know it here's how it goes down first
cyber thieves search hundreds of public
databases for high equity homes then
they pull your home's online title
forward your signature saying you sold
your home and take out loans using your
equity
insurance generally doesn't cover it
your bank or common identity theft
programs don't either protect your most
valuable asset register your address now
see if you're already a victim receive a
complete title history of your home a
100 value free go to home title lock dot
com again that is home title lock dot
com you wouldn't leave your safe open
and then your front door open so why
would you do that with regard to your
home equity which is probably your
biggest store of value go check them out
right now home title lock dot com that
is home title lock dot com okay so we've
had megan rapino and carrich levine and
then we had grimes so grimes showed up
and uh frankly i don't know anything
about grimes other than that this dress
is hideous but this person grimes who i
will assume her gender for the sake of
of argument
she showed up carrying a large medieval
style sword
now this sword is special
because again remember cosplaying this
sword is super special because this
sword was from a melted down ar-15
now um
here's the thing about that um
so
if you are going to do the swords into
plowshares routine you actually have to
beat the sword into a plowshare
what a stupid person would do is beat
the sword down into two daggers that
doesn't have the same impact so if your
idea is i will take this very dangerous
weapon and i will melt it down into a
slightly less dangerous weapon this just
makes you seem stupid
which unfortunately for us our celebrity
class most certainly are so there is
that and right now i'm just doing the
political stuff right and then there's
just the bizarre like kim kardashian
showing up wearing the outfit from
from
pulp fiction and this is just bizarre i
don't even know what's happening here
by the way
i mean we're speaking about outfits that
might be popular in afghanistan these
days this one might be popular so you
have kim kardashian but then you have uh
carolyn maloney so carol maloney is a
congresswoman from new york her net
worth is somewhere in the neighborhood
of 10 to 13 million
she's been a congressperson since 1993.
so she is not a victimized woman in the
united states because let's face it
women in the united states are not as a
class victimized that is a silly silly
contention especially given the fact
that not only do a majority of college
students not only are they female a vast
majority of college students are female
in fact there's pretty good evidence
that males are dropping out of the
college force at exorbitant rates and
nobody wants to talk about it because of
course males are the baddies males are
the patriarchy doesn't matter that
the patriarchy doesn't actually rule the
country but still so carolyn maloney
wore this dress that has these giant
banners coming out of the side of it
says saying equal rights for women ah
so much bravery
at the met gala and and i'm just going
to point out in this particular photo
cara maloney she's wearing this this
thing that says equal rights for women
by the way she's most famous in congress
for having back at the beginning of the
afghan war worn a full burka on the
floor of the house to demonstrate how
much he cared about equal rights for
women in afghanistan
meanwhile let's say that her criticism
of the biden administration for pulling
out of afghanistan and those women being
stuffed back into burqas has been at
least somewhat muted anyway in this
particular photo carolyn maloney
cosplaying she has this equal rights for
women these banners coming off and in
the background there are one two three
four five six seven women
all staffers for the met gala
who are all masked
she is not wearing a mask because she
she is a special she is a special person
now one of the things that we have been
told is that if you are vaccinated you
are still supposed to mask right this is
what the cdc now says because they're
idiots this is it because they have
decided that we have to protect the
unvaccinated from the vaccinated
and we have to protect the vaccinated
from the unvaccinated none of it makes
any sense but these are the rules we
have been told the rules by our moral
bettors that you're supposed to mask no
matter where you go and it does not
matter if everybody at the ball
had already been tested it doesn't
matter if everybody at the ball have
been vaccinated they're still supposed
to wear the mask unless you are one of
the special people if you're carol and
maloney and you want equal rights for
women equal rights for some women you
see if you're the staffing help
if you are the poor suckers who got
roped into providing the the stage
support for this little show then you
have to mask up in the background
it really is quite telling right you
have all the women in the background who
are all wearing masks because they are
part of the lower class and then you
have the specials and the specials
except for kim kardashian who's wearing
a bag over her head
all the specials are completely unmasked
contra the cdc
because they are but they're the
revolutionaries guys they are indeed the
revolution okay in one second we're
going to get to the greatest of all
cosplaying revolutionaries the
inimitable
irreverent
irreplaceable
so fresh so face
alexander ocasio-cortez so much
freshness so much faceness the fresh
fake brilliant unbelievable
revolutionary stunning iconic we're
gonna get to this in just one second
because i have some thoughts first
let us talk about a simple fact which is
you'd like to keep your home safe i like
to keep my home safe it matters a lot to
me this is why i rely on ring alarm
particularly when i'm out of town
with my ring alarm security system i'm
much more at ease when i'm on the road
or away from home my ring alarm equals
peace of mind you can protect your home
with ring alarm ring alarm is a powerful
affordable home security system you can
easily install yourself it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app for a special offer go to
ring.com it is the perfect way to start
your ring experience keep an eye on
every corner of your house with indoor
and outdoor cams see what's happening
directly from your phone protect your
home anytime from anywhere with ring
alarm go to ring.com for a special offer
on a ring alarm security kit today you
can build a system that's right for your
home have it up and running in just
minutes that's ring.com once more
ring.com
ben one of the other reasons that i love
ring is because it allows me to keep an
eye on my kids i've got three kids
they're constantly running all over my
property and if i can't find one of them
which sometimes happens i just pop up
that ring app on my phone and now i can
check out exactly where they are you can
do the same ring is great check them out
ring.com
ben for a special offer on a ring alarm
security kit today okay all of this was
mere prelude to the greatest of
revolutionary cosplayers
so fresh so unbelievably face the face
of freshness and the fresh of facemasks
aoc showed up to the met gala
now nothing says woman of the people
like showing up to a gala where the
average ticket cost 30 thousand dollars
now i assume she didn't pay for that i
assume that she was gifted the ticket by
somebody in the management at the met
gala
she wore a white dress
from a
i actually
was wondering who the maker of the dress
was
apparently the maker of the dress is
some famous shoe designer i guess they
don't even sell dresses normally so they
made it special for her
and she was wearing a special white
dress with a slogan on the back of it
reading tax the rich
tax
the rich
at the met gala
surrounded
by all of the rich people including aoc
who makes 174 000 a year not being a bar
maid but being a a person who is in
congress mouthing off on instagram
she is not a member of the lower classes
in the united states gang neither is
bernie sanders bernie sanders is a
millionaire who owns three homes
aoc is not a member of the blue collar
working class any longer
okay so aoc shows up to the met gala to
hobnob with the rich and famous now
notice again this is cosplaying the
revolution she isn't outside yelling at
the people going into the met gala that
they need to be taxed more
she's not outside telling them that they
should be giving all of the money not to
the metropolitan museum of fashion but
to actual poor people
because let me tell you something if you
donate to the metropolitan museum of art
at money ain't going to the poor
instead the idea here is that she is
she's a heroine it's iconic according to
reporters for rolling stone iconic oh
incredible
she is uh so here she is wearing this
dress that says tax the rich
and we're all supposed to swoon because
again she's not actually doing anything
revolutionary she's going to a bunch of
people who agree with her about taxing
the rich at least when they're at events
like this and then they go home and they
say to their accountant so where do i
stash my cash so i don't get taxed
that's how it actually works in
hollywood a bunch of hollywood higher
ups i'm happy to pay i'm happy to pay
the highest taxes in all the land and
then they call up
they call it burma the accountant
they're like okay
figure out where to stash cayman islands
would that work for you how do i avoid
paying what's the minimum i can pay i
notice a lot of these people are not big
on actually the giving of the charity or
the signing of a larger checks to the
federal government i've noticed
but uh aoc decides to show up and she's
going to shame them and they'll
look deeply ashamed right they they all
look as though they have been just
slapped in the face with a wet fish or
alternatively they know
that she's just part of the game
because again robespierre didn't show up
at versailles
wearing hula that said kill the monarchs
he just killed the monarchs
if you're going to be a revolutionary
you got to be revolutionary you don't
get to hobnob with the let the meat cake
crowd which is what she is doing
now there's still a lot of people in
this country who are suffering who can't
go back to work in new york city you
can't go back to work in a lot of places
because of all the vaccine requirements
aoc's district is one of the less
wealthy districts in new york
and here she is taking the joe manchin
who's really bad joe mentioned
plutocrats joe manchin i didn't see him
at the met gala
i didn't see this piece of work in the
miguel
there she was the met gala hobnobbing
with all of her fashionable friends
standing up to the patriarchy standing
up to capitalism with all of these
beneficiaries of capitalism who are
dancing them with the mask of the red
death at the ball that protects them
from from being part of the rest of the
pandemic
it's uh it is galling to say the least
for sure now i guess the dresses
designer was aurora james and she went
with her dress designer
and uh she discussed what it means to be
working class women of color at the met
yes yes wow it's like cinderella going
to the ball
yeah you well there there was aoc she
was sitting in her kitchen
doing an instagram post about how to
make a smoothie and she looked
over into the fire and she just began
sifting through the ashes for a for a
potato a crumb to eat
and that's when they began calling her
ayo cinderella
[Music]
and ao cinderella then had billy porter
arrive as the fairy godmother
and grant her her wish which was to go
to the ball with all of the special
people
wearing a dress that said on the back
tax
the rich
wow
and then she turned back into a pumpkin
she had to go back to washington dc and
hang out with all the other pumpkins
so here she was blue collar aoc
explaining her own heroism ah not all
heroes wear capes some wear two thousand
dollar dresses designed by aurora james
here here she is
when aurora and i were first kind of
partnered
uh we really started having a
conversation about what it means to be
working class women of color at the met
and oh my god
you know we can't just
play along but we need to break the
fourth wall and challenge some of the
institutions and
and
you know while
the met is known for it it's spectacle
we should have a conversation about it
well well they've known about the
spectacle we should have a conversation
about it you know what the conversation
is that you're a hypocrite that's the
conversation we're standing outside with
a sign saying give all the money to the
poor you were inside having ha after
having been gifted given a seat by the
met and partnered with aurora james who
apparently is the creative director and
founder of a luxury accessories brand
called brother vellies which by the way
i should know brother vellis i'm just
going to read you some of the prices
from their their website
okay the brother velli's products
um i'm gonna just look at their at their
their shoes right now
okay they have a tris sandal for 285
they have socks for 35 bucks a pair
which seems kind of expensive for socks
i will note
she has shoes called the beirut slide
for six hundred and fifteen dollars but
aurora these are working class women of
color
fighting back against capitalism the
patriarchy so in a second i'm gonna
explain why all of this matters because
it really does it actually does
the reason it matters is because
well you know i'll get to it in one
second first let us talk about the fact
that you do not need to go to the post
office like post office is great but you
don't actually need to go and wait in
line and then you finally get to the
front and it takes forever otherwise you
can just do it at home why not just do
it at home or do it at the office this
is stamps.com thanks to stamps.com you
don't have to go to the post office you
can mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer and pay less a lot
less with discounted rates from usps ups
and more
here at daily wire we've been using
stamps.com since 2017 we have saved
ourselves thousands and thousands of
dollars using stamps.com stamps.com
brings the services of the us postal
service and ups directly to your
computer you simply use your computer to
print official us postage 24 7. once
your mail is ready you just schedule a
pickup or drop it off it is that simple
with stamps.com you get discounts up to
40 off post office rates up to 66 off
ups shipping rates not to mention
stamps.com is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters so stop
wasting time going to the post office go
to stamps.com instead there's no risk
with my promo code shapiro you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and digital
skill no long term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in shapiro that's
stamps.com promo code shapirostamps.com
never go to the post office again okay
so why does any of this matter why does
that gala matter why does aoc and all
this why is this important the reason
it's important is because the same
people who call for tearing down the
systems are the beneficiaries of the
system if you're going to do something
like the met gala it should be a
celebration of capitalism because
frankly that's what makes all of this
possible it should be a celebration of
free markets and competition and
creativity and entrepreneurship
which is really what is happening at the
met gala instead it's a bunch of
masturbatory idiots talking about how
terrible are the systems under which we
live while simultaneously living the
highest on the hog it is possible to
live and making mockeries of themselves
in the process and you know what good
because it shows what idiots they are it
shows that for them
the political stance it's like a purse
it's just an accessory
that's all okay the political stance is
not some sort of deeply rooted belief
system for a lot of these folks it is
not about what they believe in their
heart of hearts because they are willing
to shed that in order to go to a
cocktail party with all the famous folks
what it is really about more than
anything
all of the radical left's most ardent
proposals are aoc's dress they are all
expensive dresses
built on the back of an incredibly
prosperous system saying tax the rich
it's all signaling
all it is is i'm a good person because
like i'd be a bad aoc would be a bad
person if she'd just gone to the mat
gala and didn't say tax the rich on the
back but it did say tax to the rich on
the back so now she's a good person now
she's virtuous
carol de la vine wearing a stupid bib
that probably cost a couple thousand
dollars wearing say if it hadn't said
anything we would just think look at
these decadent idiot celebrities but
but she had embroider on it peg the
patriarchy and that means that she is a
morally praiseworthy person
megan rapino would just be a whiny
soccer player playing a sport that very
few people watch except once every four
years when the media decide it's
important
and then whining about a salary contract
that she herself signed that's all she
would be except for the fact that she
walks around talking about how
victimized she is in american society
and how the institutions are bad
the greatest grift in america is living
on the back of the greatest system ever
put to paper and then talking about what
a victim you are while living high on
that system it is the most amazing grift
i've ever seen and so many of our
politicians do it and this is joe biden
who has never taken a private sector
paycheck hey joe biden has never run a
business joe biden has never done
anything worthwhile is in the man was
elected to the senate of the united
states when he was 29 years old
he is a congressional welfare case
and here he is talking about the evils
of the system that have made him worth
millions and millions of dollars
hey and by the way that system the
political patronage system that made
millions and millions of dollars because
that's why he's rich see there's a
difference between politicians who are
rich before and then go into politics
and people who are not rich and then
became rich because they were
politicians like joe biden which is kind
of despicable the
the amazing spectacle in the united
states of people
who
benefit from the system ripping the
system for pay and fun
is just it's an amazing amazing thing to
watch and you should always keep that in
mind because that's what they're doing
because what does that really amount to
in the end what it amounts to is they
are better than you they are more
morally praiseworthy than you you see
aoc is more morally praiseworthy than
you
are just a restaurateur you're just
somebody who owns a small restaurant in
rural indiana
and you know you don't think the
institutions should be torn down you
don't have the vision you're not like
ibn max kennedy you don't see the deep
roots of evil in the system
well you know getting 10 million dollar
checks from from jack dorsey over
twitter
and and running a center for anti-racism
research that to date has produced zero
research at boston university right
you're just a person who runs a business
and tries to make sure that your
employees have money to take home and
you try to put food on the table for
your kids and maybe you try to service
your customers
but you don't stand up against the
institutions which means that you're bad
and you're stupid
these people they're special they're
elite they are better than you
because they have not only succeeded in
the system they recognize the evils of
the system
and this makes them superior to you
and what does that mean
what that really means is that we are
just supposed to ignore everything they
actually do on the ground in favor of
the proposition that you are bad and you
are you are morally blameworthy
your life does not matter your your
prospects do not matter your hopes and
your dreams do not matter because you
are not part of the cosplaying
revolutionary brigade
because these folks are like a dog if
they actually caught the car they
wouldn't know what to do with it
okay really if these are if tom ford and
timothy chalamet and aoc if they ever
caught the car and they instituted
the socialist revolution that they
apparently so ardently seek
they might be quite unhappy with the
results the most ardent communists in
the united states have never lived under
communism and the most ardent
capitalists in the united states have
there is a reason for that there's a
reason that cuban expatriates come to
the united states and they understand
the evils of communism while all the
communists in the united states were
born in the united states went to our
top universities
and and again it comes down to the way
that they are going to to
re and reinstill reinforce
their own sense of moral superiority is
to crap on you
right and it comes out in everything
they do it really does
take for example coveted policy we'll
get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
life is unexpected you do need policy
genius okay you need life insurance if
you're a responsible human being you
could be walking down the street and
suddenly a trapdoor opens beneath you
and you are you find yourself in an
alternative universe where
joe biden is a good president
and aoc is brilliant and
the economy is not inflating
and in that alternative universe you
can't get back right you're just there
and your family misses you in the real
world and you can't get back at that
point you wish man i wish i had life
insurance and my family at least was
taken care of this is why you need
policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare well you could say 50 or more on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius you could save 1300 bucks
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
the licensed experts and policy genius
work for you not the insurance company
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process that kind of services
earn policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google and eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call
this exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor higher than
options from ladder ethos and bestow
getting started is simple first you head
on over to policygenius.com
shapiro you can work out how much life
insurance coverage you need compare
personalized quotes find at your best
price head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and quite important to get it right
okay we're gonna get to more on this in
just one second first you may have
noticed that the federal government has
now gone totally authoritarian when it
comes to the vaccine mandates vaccine
mandates when it comes to forcing
businesses to fire people if they refuse
to get the coveted vaccine that is an
un-american principle it is the
antithesis of freedom it is wrong it's
affecting all of us because when you
have the federal government override
federalism and decide that they are
simply going to cram down rules on the
little people that is wrong we're going
to talk about it tonight on an all-new
episode of backstage with me jeremy
boring michael moles matt walsh and
andrew clavin i'm sure the met gala will
come up as well it streams tonight 7 p.m
eastern 6 pm central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel daily wire
don't miss it you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
because these folks are your moral
bettors it doesn't matter what they do
they can do whatever they want they can
be as bad at policy as they want to be
as long as you are the target that's all
that matters now folks wonder where the
populist sort of revolt under trump came
from it came from fu that's where it
came from it came from americans looking
at stuff like this and just saying
you're declaring yourselves our moral
betters here is a giant orange pulsating
middle finger to you
and by the way here's a person who is
unrepentantly capitalist by the way
that's still the part of trump that i
actually find charming and always found
charming was the fact that trump was
like yeah i'm a capitalist and guess
what capitalism is great ticket
more of this please okay but again for
all of these folks once they have
declared themselves the morally fit and
you the unfit it doesn't matter whether
the policies that they are actually in
charge of now aoc remember is a
congresswoman she's not a singer she's
not a rapper she's not an actress she's
a congresswoman carolyn maloney is a
congresswoman and they're being treated
and feeded as though they are
celebrities okay but our politicians are
actually in charge of policy you may
have noticed the relationship between
policy and politician right they come
from the same route
so what exactly are they allowed to do
and the answer is anything so long as
they're victimizing the right people
so there's a clip that came out
yesterday
this is of commerce secretary gina
raimondo
talking about the new vaccine mandates
and she says you know what
it doesn't really matter if a few little
people lose their jobs overall there
will be job gains because then all of
the vaccinated will feel comfortable to
go back to work and we can reopen the
economy if we do these vaccine mandates
but you lost your job because you had
natural immunity and didn't want to get
the vaccine well tough beans for you
because we are the elect
are you concerned at all this could have
a worse impact on the worker shortage we
currently have people will quit their
jobs
i am not i am not you know
we need to get we have uh challenges in
this economy right now supply chains
worker shortages you know people still
afraid to fly people afraid to go back
to work
all of that can be alleviated if
everybody gets vaccinated so yes there
is a challenge now with people not going
back to work a lot of that is because
people are afraid to go back to work
okay that's such a lie the reason that
people are afraid to go back to work is
because of you
it's because of the media you know where
people aren't afraid to go back to work
red states people are back to work in
florida and they move back to work for
months
i will not stop mentioning this because
it remains a fact this is a policy
driven gap this is not an actual disease
driven gap it is a perception gap
once again the vaccinated should be fine
going back to work the vaccines are
highly successful but you guys are
attempting to drive a wedge between
americans based on vaccination status
and willingness to get the vaccine that
is unjustifiable by the science because
everyone now has the ability to get the
vaccine but you don't care if somebody
loses their job you don't care if your
policy mandate means that if we exceeded
your request daily wire might have to
fire 40 50 employees you don't care
about what happens to them because
they're the baddies you see they're bad
and you're good
and the reason we know you're good is
not because of your policies not because
your policies are actually good or right
or fair or rights-based
no it's because you're a good person and
we know you're a good person because of
who you are in opposition to
and consistency is of little consequence
here you can switch your position
at random
because once you are a member of the
elect
then there's nothing you can do that
gets you kicked out of the elect except
to sympathize with the unelect
that is all that happens
right so for example
yesterday the great and sainted dr fauci
second best doctor in america after dr
joe biden he came out and he said he's
now for mandates when it comes to air
travel now this is completely
anti-scientific
air travel has not been a vector of
disease this entire time they have hipaa
filters on the planes even at the
beginning of the pandemic when there
were no vaccines available
there was very little transmission on
planes in fact you were safer on a plane
than you were in pretty much any other
area because of the ventilation
the cdc says it much by the way the cdc
has an entire report where they said we
were surprised to learn that planes
really were not being used as vectors of
transmission now you have anthony fauci
basically saying we want to ban an
entire group of people in the united
states from being able to fly and travel
you're basically we want to put you on a
no-fly list like you're a terrorist if
you won't get vaccinated
why per se
now they say it's to protect the
vaccinated i'm not kidding you this is
their idiotic line kamala harris tweeted
this out yesterday now kamala harris
vice president of the united states
actually tweeted out by vaccinating the
unvaccinated increasing our testing and
masking and protecting the vaccinated we
can end this pandemic protecting the
vaccinated you know what protects the
vaccinated the vaccine that's why
they're called the vaccinated
i was protected the minute my antibodies
kicked in after the vaccine
protecting the vaccinated this is an
attempt to divide americans as always
okay so here's fauci saying something
completely anti-scientific but we're
supposed to believe him because after
all he is tus hyuns
i would support that if you want to get
on a plane and travel with other people
that you should be vaccinated
why
well i mean i think you should be
vaccinated generally but why is that a
precondition to travel
seriously why
and by the way this contradicts after
factory circa 2019 so in 2019 he was
directly asked by a reporter from
bloomberg so our mask is a great way of
preventing disease 2019 just prior to
the pandemic his answer sounds exactly
like joe rogan
and the best way for me to prevent
getting an infectious disease and having
to have you as my doctor is what um
wearing a mask no no no no need to do
that
somebody's i can see they're getting
ready to sneeze or cough walk away you
avoid all the paranoid aspects and do
something positive
a
good diet b you don't smoke i know i
know you don't drink at least not very
much so that's pretty good get some
exercise i know that you don't get as
much exercise as you should
that's dr anthony fauci circa 2019 but
now to be a member of the elect you have
to do what dr anthony fauci says even in
direct contradiction to it is amazing by
the way we've gone this entire pandemic
and there's been no systematic
discussion of whether americans should
exercise that is kind of an amazing
thing you can be both pro-vaccine and
pro-exercise which by the way would be
the actual scientific position here that
vaccines are good and also it is better
not to be fat
okay it is better as a health matter not
to be overweight
that does not mean there aren't people
who struggle with it but there are a lot
of people who are not doing their
exercise and not eating healthy that is
just a reality in the united states
whenever people talk about the health
gaps in the united states versus
scandinavia it's because we're way
fatter than scandinavia it's not because
our medical system sucks it's because
our medical system can't fix the fact
that many of us are gigantic
and that is just a reality
but again
anthony factor is a member of the elect
so you have to listen to him and if you
don't listen to him then you are cast
into the outer darkness and now they're
making it more more radical right zeke
emanuel says you'll be cast into the
outer darkness if you don't want to mask
or or vaccinate your small children
now again i'm wondering where like there
better be some pretty exorbitant data on
the lack of risk to children from this
vaccine because the lack of risk from
covet is well substantiated at this
point in the united states the number of
children under the age of 18 who have
died in the united states from covid is
412 over the course of a year and a half
during this pandemic as opposed to well
over 950 who died from pneumonia in that
same exact period of time here's f here
is uh zeke emmanuel however saying we
need to actually mandate that small
school children get the vaccine
only 40 of those kids 12 to 15 have
gotten fully vaccinated we really need
that number to go way up just to give
you a contrast
adults between 65 and 75 who were so
threatened before
85 percent of them are vaccinated we
need to really mandate i think 12 to 15
year olds to get the vaccine all across
the country that's unbelievable okay
what he's saying he just compared
vaccination rates among 12 to 15 year
olds for whom we are talking about maybe
a couple a few dozen deaths everyone
terrible but a few dozen deaths over the
course of a year and a half he's
comparing that to people and their rates
65 and older which is everyone who died
in the united states
is a disease that heavily skews toward
killing the elderly
meanwhile the administration again
contra the science is saying that
everybody should get boosters its own
cdc is like nope
the cdc and the who are both like yeah
we're not seeing it guys like we looked
at the data and um what we are saying is
that the vaccination had 95
effectiveness against severe disease
from both delta and alpha
more than 80 effectiveness in protecting
against infection from those variants
they noted that waning antibody levels
don't necessarily correlate with a
decrease in effectiveness against severe
disease because you got t cell and b
b-cell immunity right
boosters may eventually be needed save
the scientists but there could be risks
if boosters were widely introduced too
soon or too frequently
because it might create adverse
reactions when you do too many shots too
fast
and yet the biden administration is
rushing forward with this sort of stuff
and apparently if you note any of this
then you will be cast into the outer
darkness and then then you're one of the
bad people
it's it's all about the it's all about
being a member of the elect versus a
member of the non-elect and that is why
our politics are so broken and they're
not getting fixed any time soon because
the culture war issue of our time is
whether you think your neighbor is a bad
person it is not the vaccine
it is not
it is not racial issues it is not tax
issues it is none of that
it's whether you are oriented against
the institutions of the country and are
therefore part of the revolutionary
vanguard while benefiting from it or
if you're not
that is how we determine
there is a reason why i mean there's a
poll that just came out
a scott rasmussen national survey and
this is backed by other data i mean
kirsten solza sanderson did a poll last
year basically finding the same thing
and what this poll found is that 57
percent of democratic voters believe
that supporters of donald trump are a
serious threat to the nation
so they literally believe that half of
their fellow americans are a serious
threat to the nation itself
that is as opposed to say the taliban
only 44 of democrats believe that the
taliban are threats to the country or
believe that china is a threat to the
country
or believe that defund the police
activists are a threat to the country
of democrats believed unvaccinated
americans are a threat to the country
again once you're vaccinated they're not
a threat to you
okay only 37 believe that russia is a
threat to the country
fully 57 believes that donald donald
trump supporters are a threat to the
country
now if you look at how
non-identifying voters
rank these issues in terms of who they
think is a threat to the country
not gop not done in this poll
the top threats according to the
independent voters are in order taliban
china defund the police activists
unvaccinated americans russia donald
trump supporters illegal immigrants and
socialists and trump supporters and
socialists are basically on par with one
another according to sort of independent
voters
okay but when you take a large
percentage of the country 40 of the
country and you say what makes you good
or what makes you bad is your agreement
with my dumb slogan on the back of my
address and anything that we say
together that is oriented against this
other group of people who don't care if
they lose their jobs they're the baddies
then what you end up with is a country
that is broken beyond repair and you're
not gonna it's not a shock that you're
gonna end up with the sorting mechanism
that you've seen in terms of american
population movements
it is not a shock that you've seen
people like me and my family move from
california to florida because who wants
to live in an area where your neighbors
look at you cross-eyed because you voted
a way that didn't want you to vote or
because you live a lifestyle they don't
want you to live who wants to do that
the answer is nobody and so what you're
gonna end up with because of the culture
war stuff it is all culture war all the
way down donald trump was not elected
because of his economic program donald
trump was not elected because of his
foreign policy program no one could name
what those programs were in 2016. he was
elected
because donald trump was a giant fu to
this entire group of people who say that
anyone who disagrees with them is part
of the of the damned and are going
straight to hell
there is a paganistic religious
perspective and what you see at the met
gala every single year is the pagan
priesthood at work
and if you if you can't see that that is
why
it's amazing because i think the
independent
voter the republican voter they look at
democrats and like i don't understand
why people
are are treating joe biden or treating
this administration or treating barack
obama for that matter treating these
people like they're good at what they do
like who looks at the way that these
folks handle the issues and thinks to
themselves i those people need more
control over my life you understand for
the people who vote for that it is not
about
that group of people having more control
over their lives it's about they are
willing to take the hit so that they
will have control over your life there's
a very famous episode
in the uh extended bible not five books
of moses but in the prophets there's a
very famous episode in which two women
come to king solomon
and they are fighting over the identity
of a baby so they both had babies at the
same exact time one their baby died the
other the baby lived
and the woman whose baby lived is
accusing the woman whose baby died of
stealing the babies they come in front
of king solomon and they asked solomon
to solve the riddle whose baby is this
and solomon says
my solution is i'm going to cut the baby
in half
and the woman whose baby died says fine
and the woman whose baby is lit whose
baby lived says no i don't care whether
or not this is uh it doesn't matter to
me if if she i'd rather she have the
baby than the than the baby die and
solomon immediately says okay you're
obviously the mother because you care
whether the baby lives or dies
understand that for the radicals in our
society the destruction is the point it
is not about what it is replaced with
and it is not about destruction of the
system it is about destruction of you it
is about destruction of people who do
not think like they do they don't care
if they have to take the hit in new york
by vaccinating
by vaccine mandate and and you gotta
take them a vaccine to get on a plane
because it doesn't affect them it
affects you
this is more about revenge against
people who do not think the way they do
than it is about promulgating anything
good or beneficial they don't care
whether you get vaccinated if they did
they would actually try to convince you
to get vaccinated if you're unvaccinated
they don't care about any of that what
they care about most deeply is their
continuing sense of moral superiority
and your continued feeling of moral
inferiority
and if they can elect somebody who's
going to bang on all the people they
hate most then all the rest of it
they can go to whatever fancy cocktail
parties they want and be as hypocritical
as they want they can hang out with aoc
and the celebs at whatever tony ritzy
gala they want to go to
because they are better than you
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon as the matt wall show it
airs at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check
it out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crans the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show